this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists when humans cling we
get dragged by whatever we cling to
material possessions careers status
achievements ideologies the town we grew
up in
toxic relationships to cling is to give
up a piece of freedom just to retain
something that brings with it a sliver
of pleasure and often a world of misery
that's what we're talking about today
with a very special guest here in the
studio
we have a storyteller a performer a
grammy-nominated comedian ladies and
gentlemen please welcome the new and
impossibly improved lisa lampanelli
oh my god
you guys have made my dreams come true
i'm obsessed with the minimalist i can't
believe it it's the only podcast that i
buy as a patreon subscriber because i'm
like i cannot get enough of these too i
love that poem
you're the age group that i always
thought would hate me because you're the
age group that cancels everybody yeah
right however you're just on the tail
end of it i was like thank you for like
liking me enough to have me on the show
yeah i'm freaking obsessed i'm busy
loving things and using people
wait it's the other one
no but seriously i love the podcast
thank you for having me we love you on
my bucket list thanks so much for coming
on i mean it's it truly is an honor to
have you on here that was so funny i'm
always shocked when anyone has even
heard of me because i have incredibly
low selfies are you kidding me i used to
i used to get the comedy central rose
channel yeah exactly that was so good
back in the day and i have a theory
about why josh is a fan of mine if you'd
like to hear it
yes okay when i was listening to your
best-selling book love people use things
on audio which i also own in hardcover i
was listening and you told a really
sweet story about your mom and how she
took you and all the kids to the park
and how she said what could nowadays be
viewed as a quote unquote racist joke
and i used to always you know this was
my comedy i made fun of every single
type of person hoping they would all
feel included and your mom said this
thing to this black kid it was so
adorable she said something about if you
can reiterate it oh
yes i could well it was a joke where she
indicated a stereotype
and i said to myself and you said it was
a beautiful moment because you realized
your mother really brought people
together with humor yes and i said oh my
god that's why josh probably is a fan of
mine because deep down inside
you just know that all jokes despite the
target and if the target feels included
it's about love and inclusion so that's
what i said i have this little fantasy
that i'm josh's mom now
so if you want you could come for
christmas and i'll have i'll even like
take that kitty or something that kid
seems real cute
i love it
i don't want to ruin my mom's punch line
so it's in the book you know
no it's fantastic but what i what i will
say is there was something about humor
that allowed us to talk about some of
the some of life's most difficult most
challenging things you know we grew up
in a really terrible situation and i
felt like there was so much weight that
it required that levity yeah and my mom
was just this
this source of humor all the time i
loved that story so much and seriously
when i was doing comedy i was doing i
was staying up for 31 years
and then abruptly retired three years
ago just because i had to minimize my
life you know i was just like this
career isn't serving me anymore i really
want to downsize everything and it was
you guys are new at touring and stuff
but if you've done it for 30 years
you're like okay another hotel room
another theater you're not a sightseer
like you literally fly in and see three
things airport hotel theater and that's
it that's right so i was like oh this is
not
feeling good anymore i started becoming
a noticer of my own life and i was like
i want to just declutter that out of my
life i love it and it's sort of like
when i wrote to you guys and was like
hey man i'd love to come on the show i
was like i literally got rid of
so much other than
things
you know his career husband and by the
way still friends with him because he is
a good guy um i had four houses at one
point i mean for one person what are you
kidding me would you a big shot ryan i
thought you were extreme with two living
rooms i know right a little in four
hours my house had three living rooms oh
my goodness weird flex but okay yeah i
know it is an odd thing to brag about
but now i live literally in the home i
grew up in i love my parents house it's
it's just literally home it's always
been in my phone labeled home
there's a reason i probably never
changed that and i was like oh this is
where i'm supposed to be and now it's
just me and the two little doggies and
it's just really cool got rid of 90 of
my stuff and a lot of that is in thanks
to you guys
because that first netflix special just
blew me away well let's talk about that
so on this minimal episode we're going
to talk about clinging to things and
also letting go of things on the maximal
we're going to talk we're going to
disagree about attachment i think
because we've actually had some fans
disagree about our our thoughts on
attachment recently and maybe even ryan
i disagree but also i want to talk about
commitment and also ryan called me this
morning he wanted to talk to you about
being canceled so we're gonna talk about
that on the maximal episode that's over
on patreon the minimalist private
podcast patreon.com slash the minimalist
but lisa let's talk about
how did you stumble across the
minimalists oh my god okay so
i
you know you retire you're like what is
my life going to consist of oh my god i
have no identity and of course that
means let's just watch a lot of tv so
i'm flipping around to netflix and i'm
like oh these guys all right that's cool
i mean it's a choice between you and the
tony robbins documentary which one am i
gonna listen to so i watched this and
i'm like oh okay
it resonated so what was enough to make
me subscribe not subscribe yet i just
started downloading the podcast because
i'm not really a podcast person so i was
like oh this is really cool and then the
second special came out i did the 30-day
challenge i know i'm gonna do another
one and it's i don't even need an
accountability partner because i'm that
much of a badass okay i'm cobra kyle i
believe it so then i was like oh i need
more of this so i subscribe to the
patreon because i'm like oh i have to
hear like the deeper stuff so yeah it
was it was amazing and again my age
group i'm 60 but i'm the world's oldest
millennial i literally get it i get like
why my age group sucks and i like
totally like everything i think that the
kids today like so i enjoy it so much
and i look forward to it every week you
guys better not take vacation because
i'll be really mad and what will i
listen to then the sounds of the silence
that is like the biggest compliment ever
i think like your story is so important
for our listeners to hear because you
did you kind of had it all you had the
success and my favorite philosopher jim
carrey oh i love him
yeah that he has that quote that we used
in the first documentary but i wish
everyone could become rich and famous
just to see that that's not the answer
and i get asked all the time they're
like yeah you know ryan i get it man you
had it all you were making six figures
you had the job you had the vacations
you had all of it and it didn't make you
happy and i get that you know
intellectually but i just want to try it
out for myself i just want to make sure
that it's not something that i want so
yeah i think stories like this really
kind of it just helps answer that
question of how do i get rid of that
desire to have everything
and uh and just move forward with life
with with you know with a meaningful
life well the thing is about it though
it's weird when you do retire from
something that's really public like you
never really hear of comics actors or
singers retiring me and daniel day-lewis
so i'm in like really good company
so i'm like i just and jim carrey
actually he and i had developed a tv
show that we sold to hbo at one point
and it didn't get made and it was a
blessing like it's always a blessing
when you look back and go oh my god
thank god i wasn't a good enough actor
to pull that off so jim carrey had said
to me once we are in the united states
of avoidance
we avoid everything every feeling and
i'm like okay i was medicating with food
i i had to lose you know get surgery and
lose the weight that was another
declutter i was medicating with
achievement and literally nothing makes
you feel better like it's insane i would
buy so much stuff and again i could
afford it so it was easy to let myself
get away with it yeah like you don't
you know if your bank account's great
like what do you care about you buy
eight louis vuittons right here's your
big shot but i always go wow it was
interesting to go hmm 10 seconds have
made me feel better than not so much
yeah and you guys really got in my head
though yesterday this was really funny
because um it's stressful being out here
with the hotel situation it's you know
la's a little crazy right now with the
coveted stuff and i was like i just have
to get this not i have to go to louis
vuitton i go i'm just gonna go to
forever 21 how bad can it be and i'm
like wait a minute i'm going on the
minimalist tomorrow i don't think i
should go to forever 21. you guys helped
me not buy a three dollar shirt that
will disintegrate in one washroom oh man
you're welcome or i'm sorry i don't know
which one it was crazy but no i don't i
think everyone's trying to fill the hole
yeah and i get it but it's impossible
with other with outward things yeah and
what we're doing is we're clinging to
those things so it's it's
buying the the louis vuitton bag and
that wasn't enough so the second one
might be enough right i'm gonna hold on
to that first one that didn't really
bring me the joy that i thought that it
would promise but then i'm going to move
on to this next thing and we know that
other stuff isn't making us happy but we
still hold on to it the four houses is a
great example what were your four houses
filled with this was ridiculous okay i
was fancy for a while
even though like i'm so totally lower
middle class you know my folks were just
working worker people and i it was just
i had them decorated beautifully i had a
decorator this i who the who do i think
i am i'm doing something it's a comic
who's an idiot like come on so it was
basically stuff and you know what's
funny about the purses i did years about
three years ago i sold all the purses i
sold all the jewelry i mean everything
that was worth anything because i'm like
oh money's good and i can put that in
the bank and i can retire
so i'm getting rid of stuff and i
noticed about
six months ago when i moved in back into
my childhood home i hel had held on held
on to this one gucci purse and one gucci
wallet because i had memories of when i
first made it oh i don't want to tear up
my mom and dad came to see me in vegas
and it was the first time
they
were like oh they i mean they were
always proud of me but they were like oh
she deserves this you know you you can
you know i had that good memory and then
i go i bet if i sell this i can grieve
it
and not feel i have to hold on to it and
do you know
i sent it into the company sold it
and i just it's going through the grief
and mourning that's what i think we're
afraid of and i go wow a week of
mourning over this memory that i still
have within me yeah
oh
wow now i don't have to have that thing
in my house and you're right i i fought
you guys like crazy in my own head going
sentimental i love sentimental i love
sentimental and i do and it's still a
lot of stuff i have is sentimental most
of my stuff yeah but i'm like that
particular thing
could go to a greater good
so it's very interesting stuff and
there's there's an incredible sense of
relief on the other side of the grieving
and on the other side of the morning we
just did an event in phoenix recently
with uh dr joanne cacciatore and she has
this great book it's a really short book
called grieving is loving and it talks
about the death of obviously loved ones
and grieving their death but then there
are all these deaths that we go through
all the time it's grieving the loss of a
house so it's grieving the loss of a
purse it sounds silly but yeah but we
tie up so much
sentimentality we tie up so much meaning
into these things but of course if
everything has value by definition
nothing has value right because if
everything's so valuable to you and you
have well if the average household has
300 000 items in it that means lisa
lampanelli had 1.2
oh million god not anymore ninety
percent of my stuff go on you know what
i just one of my houses was like at the
beach and i realized my sister had
inherited from my parents um their house
at the cape which is small it's nothing
fancy but i go oh i bet they love that
there is so much joy to me going oh my
god i bet somebody will love this my
sister was so stoked and i said if you
don't like it just give it to goodwill
like good cause whatever and she's like
oh my god i love it so there's something
really good about finding things a good
home however
i said i can't be so beholden to that
belief
that if it doesn't have a good home i
keep it right so i go now i leave that
box by the outside door i put it right
in there and i'm like okay you know what
that's going and even if it's not a
quote-unquote good home because we could
keep everything thinking oh no until
yeah until it has a good home
it's not a reality all the time so i
just love letting stuff go and you
should hear me quote you guys i am like
a beast and i don't even credit you i'm
going to act like it's all my ideas i
literally we're giving you permission i
just go you know guys i'd be i can't get
josh's cadence perfect
like you know how he does real nice he
does a big k i love that i'm gonna play
him in his biopic
um
but when you say this stuff about just
going okay
if it's not you don't get more joy or
happiness or whatever
adding things it's subtracting things
and every person's agreed with me after
they've thought about it they go oh yeah
even in design take one thing out it
looks better yeah so i mean you guys
you're doing it you're you're changing
people's lives unlike me lisa lampanelli
well lisa we got some audience questions
here let's go ahead and dive into a few
of these i think we start with elena
from facebook
i'm clinging to the hope i once had how
do you redirect when life changes your
path so i wanted to talk about this
since we're talking about clinging today
there's this word that we
we use all the time and it's hope and
we think of it as as inerrant and good
all the time but sometimes our hope can
make us miserable if we're hoping or for
clinging to hope of something that we
know can't possibly happen maybe we had
some path set aside for us and oh i hope
this is gonna work i'm touring for 30
years i hope i'm going to enjoy this
someday
right and so here's something pithy for
you i know it's not the lightning round
but disappointment doesn't exist without
hope and so it's that's not to say get
rid of all of your hopes but choose your
hopes wisely because otherwise you might
get dragged by clinging to some of those
hopes well yeah i've said a lot that i
find hope completely useless
i don't think it's a good thing to have
i think it's i like reality and i like
going you know i'm gonna try my best to
make this thing work and if it doesn't
i'll grieve it and that's fine but you
have to grieve it we're talking about
she's talking about i think two
something i talked about on my podcast
called death of a dream
death of a dream is where you know the
little girl wants to be the ballerina
eventually the 40 year old woman has to
go oh it's kind of sad it never happened
or i wanted kids or i want my death of a
dream was i never wanted kids but i
always wanted grandkids and you can't
have one without the other so i'm like
yeah but kids not yours but kids suck so
i'm like not gonna
agree with that yeah
yeah so it's like i had to grieve the
fact that oh i didn't have grandkids but
i do have eight nieces and nephews so i
could pretend so and and also
driving in l.a is so filled with death
of a dream for me because having sold tv
shows having been like somebody in the
entertainment business it's like oh
maybe my dream was to be a great actress
but that's not what happened so i could
be sad about it
and move on but i the problem is nobody
is willing to be sad first and you gotta
just like that book you mentioned you
gotta just be sad at least for a little
bit and go wow it's a shame but i can
move on yeah that's right the death of a
dream it could we often talk about how
and rob bell we got this from robel uh
you know you have to have a funeral for
what you wish was
and that really helps to get the
grieving process kicked off and i'll
tell you too there are a lot of things
in my life i look back on like my youth
for example you know at 40 i'm like i
get hurt snowboarding it takes me a
little longer to heal than when i was
25. right and i really look at that my
past stuff like oh man i was i really
took it i didn't take advantage of my
youth and i have all these regrets but i
can also look at that and really
appreciate what was and the
opportunities that i have now and yes
i'll never be 25 again but i can
certainly start doing things now that my
50 year old self is going to be happy
about so yes so instead of looking at my
past and clinging and wishing i was
there it's like have a funeral for what
you wish was
appreciate what you had and then look at
yourself 10 years from now and ask
yourself like what can i do now i'm not
going to have this feeling so i don't
have this feeling in 10 years it's so
true like for instance i always joke
about how i do things
now really badly um we did an episode on
my podcast about
daring to suck at something because you
can't be good at something eventually
till you suck at it i'm sure your first
episode here wasn't your best episode
i'm sure episode 400 is better than
episode one so
i
suck horribly at ballroom dancing
but i'm gonna do it fully and have fun
with it and be awful at it twice a week
with stefan
and go you know what suppose i'm 80 and
in 20 years and i am the oldest winner
of dancing with the stars yeah that
would be hilarious so you go at it not
with the hope that you're going to do
that but with this cute little hobby
idea i've turned everything i do in my
life into a hobby so for instance i'm
doing a podcast with these two
millennial guys and we
i view it as a hobby i don't need to
make more money i don't need to be the
person who you know changes people's
lives i can just have fun so i think if
we look at everything as fun that's how
stand-up comedy started for me sitting
around a diner with guys writing jokes
and now i'm doing that again with these
guys i'm like this is cool so i think
what we have to do is just shift it to
doing it without attachment yes and the
results don't matter dude because we're
all going to die someday anyway and just
go oh i had fun in that moment but in
the fun not in a hedonistic way yeah you
know oh that was joyful and sweet
immersed in joy is the way that i look
at it because our friend tk coleman
talks about how dreams don't come true
decisions do
and
and if i were to expand on that i i
think about having these dreams that are
not hopes but they're sort of adjustable
dreams it's something i really enjoy
doing i would like to do that yeah for
me at age 40 now i'm not going to make
it into the nba i've just decided at
this point i have something to say you
wouldn't have done that at 20.
how dare you i hate to shatter your
dream but you're friendly
ellie
this is a wake-up call hey i'm an inch
taller than john stockton
that's true
i respect that yeah anyway um but if
your dream's adjustable and what is the
dream it's oh i really enjoy basketball
okay well maybe i can coach basketball
maybe i can be an athletic trainer
there's different things you can do that
are in that same realm and so by
expanding the dream making it more
adjustable not hoping for one specific
individual
specific outcome that we have to have
and if i don't get this my life will be
devastated like you said with comedy
when you first started comedy you were
writing jokes it was about the immersion
of the joy eventually at some point
though it became an attachment to an
outcome somewhere can you talk about
that yes
i remember my f the way i decided to
start comedy was i was working at
rolling stone magazine i was a
journalist before i'd gone to college
for journalism i'm driving to see my
first nephew who had just been born
and by the way he's having a baby this
week isn't that crazy okay it was like
30 years ago so i'm driving and i hear
an ad on the radio
you know for rent to dj this company
like who you know would you dj parties
and i'm like oh i bet if i do that first
i can work up the nerve to talk on stage
because i always kind of knew i had a
gift for like a little humor yeah and
then what happened was i started sitting
around you know after that that was
joyful and then i would sit around with
these other beginning comics and we
write material and we just have fun but
then what happens is the worst thing
happens to you is you get success and
you get like little glimmers of like ooh
this could be a career
and i'm like oh and i think the big
moment where i probably decided this
isn't for me anymore was i had sold out
carnegie hall and radio city music hall
in a space of three months that was huge
so that's like 10 000 seats yeah holy
moly combined so i was like wow and it
was great
but you know all i really remember about
that night is the family stuff which is
a big indicator of my parents being
there my brother and sister and all that
and remember i got off stage and the
head alive nation says to me wow next
madison square garden and it completely
he didn't mean it bad no i was
encouraging you yes and it deflated me
and i'm like oh my god it's never enough
i think that's the first time i thought
it's never going to be enough and i
think it was at that point there was a
little internal shift of like i bet i
have to get out of this yeah and it's
just like okay and thank god i have good
people around me who are like yeah you
can get any time you want yeah you know
you can downsize you can save money you
can just be a human so now everything i
do is just like human but that attaching
to
oh well maybe i don't feel fulfilled at
radio city but madison square garden
might do the trick it doesn't no nothing
fills the hole yeah and these these
clingings they're different types so
it's clinging to stuff or clinging to
success and in our culture those things
are societally acceptable in fact you
should be more successful you should
make more money you should buy more
things or the right things or better
things or luxury things and there's
nothing wrong with success or
achievement or stuff the problem is when
it becomes the pursuit
then that is what is making us miserable
we have a question here from jonathan in
boston my mother recently passed away
and i am now responsible for dispersing
her many possessions which she
unfortunately held so close
she was well aware of my own efforts to
live with less
but never assigned specific items that
she'd want other people to have i think
ultimately she knew i would figure it
out
but here's where things get troubling
i know that in essence there are certain
items she would have loved others to
have
and she would have wanted them
to think that she had them particularly
in mind
so for me i generally don't mind
tiptoeing the line between falsity and
truth when i'm aiming for good ends
but at the end of the day i don't want
people to feel burdened by objects that
a dead person supposedly wanted them to
have
so now if i were to proceed it would be
with good intention but i'm simply
shooting in the dark at this point
do either of you happen to have concrete
advice or general insights that might
help me as i move forward
that is the best question right now in
my life and i'll tell you why i'm
totally taking over your show i notice
your guests don't talk that much but
let's just change that for me all right
no but seriously i'm my mom passed april
30th i was lucky enough that i was
living in the house while she was in
assisted living so i got rid of all the
broken moldy or anything ruined because
it's not my stuff it's her things
so when she passed she left certain
things to certain people and i even said
to them openly i said if you don't want
this bedroom set don't worry about it
like it doesn't hurt it won't hurt her
posthumous feelings it doesn't hurt mine
we can set you can sell it and then you
know whatever i said or i could keep it
it doesn't matter i love this house the
way it is but i
feel like
the people who didn't declutter like my
mom they need us to
care take a little bit and go huh i'm
looking at this thing mom would have
wanted so and so i haven't let me tell
the little white lie so right now i do
tell the little white lies it's weird
though it's like creepy that his
question is literally what i'm doing now
because again they don't have to be
burned by it if you give the caveat
where you just go hey i think mom had
mentioned you might want this cabinet
however if you don't i'd be happy to
take it and it wouldn't hurt her so i
think if as long as you let people make
their adult decision you're okay yeah i
think that's that's the key here so with
jonathan if your mom wanted these items
to go to a specific person she would
have told you so maybe she gave you a
list of here are the 17 items i want to
go to these 17 people great that's made
it really easy for you now if you're now
trying to get into her brain and her
intentions you can do that to the best
of your ability but that's simply
offering it hey i think my mom would
have wanted you to have this if not
totally fine no offense i'll find it a
home where someone else will get value
from it yeah absolutely you know if my
grandma one time she had like a basement
full of stuff from the whole family and
she gave us a week she's like hey she
called us all up and she's like i have
all of your guys i don't know whose is
who's down here but uh just come over
and if you want it grab it if not it's
going in the garage sale so you know
that's just one example of what jonathan
can do here you but you do have to form
a plan and you also have to
you know hold these people who the items
are
supposed to be given to hold them
accountable and give them the option uh
but i'll tell you what man if you let
other people's desires dictate your
actions though it's you're gonna be
miserable and that's right now where
jonathan is is because he's like oh i
have the burden of my mother's desires
to find all these things good homes you
can do your best uh if you have to
donate the rest that's that's okay
um yeah your mom isn't gonna have her
feelings hurt but i also think too part
of it is because i've done this i don't
know if he's doing it but i just imagine
this um
this problem is almost clutter meaning
it's it's hard to grieve a parent or a
grandparent and maybe this is helping
put off that grief a little bit so i
think because i've done that i mean a
million times when my dad passed five
six years ago i was like you know well
let me carry take my mom so anything to
not feel
sadness over like my favorite person in
the world not being here anymore so it's
all very interesting to look at and i
love by the way just on a different note
the giving the people a deadline to pick
it up is that's badass of your
grandmother she was like totally cool
because it is her space yeah you know
right now the house is mine the contents
aren't i don't have any urgency to get
rid of it but what i did do and he might
want to do this also is you say
hey i'm not going to get rid of anything
i don't need to declutter mom's stuff
but i'll let you know if i need the
space and then give you a deadline
and by the way i just want to say to all
the grandmas out there because they're
all listening by the way
stop it no one wants your silver because
silver freaking is the one possession
that sucks because you have to it's all
black like you remember in the old days
they'd have tea services that stuff is
getting sold i don't care what even
members of my family who are super
sentimental like me were like no bye
girl
yeah
lisa brings up a great point and i think
this is the key for jonathan is if you
are
always trying to solve everyone else's
problems that might be an excuse to
avoid your own problems you can tweet
that podcast sean
now jonathan i'm gonna send you a couple
tickets to our
uh boston event it's no carnegie hall
it's just this
little place where are you playing the
wilbur the well i used to play the
wilbur all the time i love it it's a
beautiful venue i'm going to co-host
your show up there
we'd love to have you one of our events
we want to talk about this are you
kidding me come on
all right hell yeah yeah committed right
here i'm committing
to it
so uh we're going to 20 cities it's
called the love people use things for
the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you we just got
back from texas and we had three cities
there we were in denver and in phoenix
and salt lake city and we're going to be
all over the place both coasts we'll be
in canada for a little bit the
minimalists.com
tour you can find the city nearest you
but jonathan we're going to send you a
couple tickets to our boston event ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and comments to
four six 937-202-4650 four are you
impressed i didn't have to look at the
piece of paper for that thank you so
much lisa
you have no idea how hard i've been
working on remembering that i heard you
screw it up
one time
at least once
i think you got it from here on out all
right all right
um anyway uh so lisa during the
lightning round you know this already
but this is where we do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response and
would it be okay with you at some point
if i said tweet that podcast
we also put the text to these minimal
maxims in the show notes so you can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media if you like and now you can find
all of those minimal maxims in one place
thanks to our good friend jessica lynn
williams that's minimalmaxims.com
so we have a question here from
sebastian
how do you stop clinging to the security
of a good paying job
so a good paying job now this is the
perfect question for elise i'm gonna
give you something pithy that is a
indirect answer to this and we can
expand on a little bit so here is here's
my pithy answer love begins at the place
where clinging
ends
and so i think quite often we cling to a
relationship we cling to a job we
thought we would love we cling to the
items or the status or the trophies
whatever it might be
because
we confuse those things for love but
real love begins and we've let go of the
clinging so that's not a direct answer
here's here's my real answer security is
is a misnomer because if other people
are in charge of your destiny then there
is no real security no real
freedom in that by the way so is so is
good good is also a misnomer here a good
paying job yeah it might pay you well
financially but it sounds like it's
stressing you out in other ways so it's
not paying you well psychologically i
agree like
literally what would you rather the
money and the false construct of
security which doesn't exist because
tomorrow another madoff could steal
everything anyway
or going i have peace every day when i
wake up i'd rather i remember living in
a studio apartment in the city my first
place i ever bought it was literally so
small that you could plug in your vacuum
cleaner when you used to have to plug in
vacuums in the bathroom and reach every
place and i was so happy in it because
it was small and cute so
i mean to me
i guess it's like wow i'd rather live in
one room
and have peace and wake up going oh my
god my day is my own and i even if i
work at a coffee shop or whatever i get
you know happiness from
it's better than that idea of quote
security which doesn't exist yeah and
it's easy for me to say having saved
money and been like overly responsible
and it's easy to give that advice to
people which advice as you guys have
said is useless but i think just the
idea of peace has to outweigh
quote unquote security you know i think
though for a lot of people like
you're obviously making like really
awesome money um it would be hard for
people to let that go i mean yeah you're
able to save up some but still to walk
away from that like there's something
there that you know i think
uh what uh sebastian can take away from
this i mean you you did walk away from a
probably a better paying job than what
sebastian has yeah yeah unless that's
sebastian maniscalco he's making 50
million dollars a year oh my goodness i
love him but the fact is yeah you go wow
i'm not going to be having that paycheck
and you know what's really weird and my
business manager says this all the time
he goes don't worry every person who
retires has this where
nothing's coming in
because we didn't i didn't do a ton of
movies or anything those are not a lot
of residuals and you're still spending
so you're like oh my god is that okay
and it's like no no you've done the
right thing by saving this but yeah you
can't and clinging
is the best word for that just the idea
of
the security is making me happy yeah
security doesn't make you happy um you
know tony what's not tony um wayne dyer
had said
we don't want the million dollars in the
bank we want the feeling of having a
million dollars in the bank
so i love that tweet that podcast sean
but make sure you credit the long
departed wayne dyer
if i were to summarize what you're
saying though here's something else that
podcast sean can tweet it
peace
is not for sale right peace is priceless
oh yes wow
tweet that podcast sean yeah tweet it
off
just one tweet at the time this whole
podcast here's my pithy answer uh
sincere actions arise from sincere
desires and the thing is is like
sebastian here his sincere desire is not
to make a bunch of money now does this
mean sebastian should quit his job
tomorrow no of course not as clear as
you have to start a podcast right
exactly it works
exactly but but it does mean that
something is arising within sebastian
that he does need to make a change it
doesn't have to be tomorrow
unfortunately though what we do is we
wait until this pressure cooker
situation builds up and we feel like we
have to do something tomorrow i know
that's where i was with the corporate
world i wanted to as soon as you know we
started doing the minimalists i was like
oh man maybe i could just like go and i
couldn't i had it took me a year year
and a half to like really form a plan to
work that plan oh by the way i was going
to college i was working 60 70 sometimes
80 hours a week and i was writing for
the minimalists it wasn't sustainable
but there was an end in sight so
sebastian if anything that you get from
this is start to form a plan to make
this transition away from your job if
that's what you want to do to me it
sounds like he is looking for permission
to at least starting to to think in that
direction you're right and as the queen
of all of america and beyond you have my
permission sebastian make that plan get
out of it amen lisa we got so much more
to talk about but first emma do you got
something for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners hey ryan hey
josh this is lisa from minnesota my
advice to your listeners who are moving
and are wondering what to take and what
to leave behind is
imagine you are in your new home and you
open a box
and you there is a thing that you are
wondering about whether you want to take
and are you thinking
wow i'm so glad to see this i cannot
wait to use this in my new home or are
you thinking oh man what the heck was i
thinking why did i pack this what the
heck am i going to do with this
so
hopefully this will make things more
clear to you listeners thanks
hi my name is jamie middleton and i live
in orlando florida i did have some ideas
about um
things with kids i
recently in within the last couple of
years on my birthdays and christmas i
said you know i don't want things i'd
rather just do things with you guys i'd
rather have experiences so we take a
trip
or we go someplace really fun or special
also
instead of buying things for your kids
we like have a membership to a science
museum a children's museum
and those are great things to ask for if
people are looking for gifts for you as
a family or for your kids get a zoo
membership or ask for a museum
membership because you can make that
last all through the year and those are
places that your children can go and
play with quote-unquote toys
that are free that belong to someone
else and they have to manage the clutter
and you don't all right y'all big thanks
to lisa lampanelli check out her podcast
it's called what's it called losers with
a dream and that is a line from one of
my famous roasts because all three of us
on my podcast are losers but we have
dreams also lisa lampanelli.com we'll
put a link to all of that including her
podcast and her social media in the show
notes now lisa we're going to talk to
you a whole bunch more on the maximal
episode this week folks can check that
out we got a bunch of surprise questions
for you as well patreon.com
the minimalist but first real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist so last week we were in
denver and um i was just walking around
and we were going from the hotel to the
venues a little comedy works is actually
where we performed that place yeah
that's great and so it felt like a
comedy show too like we were on stage so
good and you know people are are you our
jokes were like five to ten percent
funnier just because we're in a comedy
club yeah
it's like also they're not going there
expecting jokes so everything ends up
being funny anyway i was walking to the
venue from the hotel and this lady stops
me on the street she's maybe mid-60s
late 60s and just a sweet lady she's
like hey you're the minimalist guy
and i'm like yeah hi how are you doing
can i get a hug and she's like yeah it'd
be wonderful are you coming to our event
it's right here that comedy works is
right down the block she's like i didn't
even know about it i introduced you to
her later because we saw her again
walking
and um she she comes up to me and she
goes i just want you to know that i
really enjoy
the instagram reels you guys have been
sharing wow wow that's great she goes
i've had this strange relationship with
my daughter and it's been the way that
i've been able to reconnect with my
daughter look at us and so we're sharing
little bite-sized versions of the
podcast little one minute podcast thanks
to danny unknown over here and uh jordan
no more podcast shawn all sort of
working together to share these one
minute podcast on tiktok and on
instagram you can check those out we're
doing it like twice a week so if you
want little shareable bits of the
podcast if you're in for someone like
you know i want to share minimalism with
someone but i can't get them to watch an
hour-long documentary well here's a
one-minute clip on tick-tock or on
instagram we're at the minimalists on
both platforms i'm still trying to talk
him into doing some tick-tock dances but
oh you have to do you gotta shake it and
by the way
by the way that 65-year-old woman was me
so thank you so much i love those no
that's a great idea the one minute i
love it well it's been a great like and
i know jessica who helps out with our
social media she's our social media
manager she she's been telling us about
all of these and i've been looking at
the comments she's sending them over all
these people are saying oh this is so
great because now i can share this with
my friends or family who just want to
know more about minimalism but i don't
feel like i'm beating them over the head
with a 60-minute podcast or something
like that that's great for our
added value segment this week well we'd
like to end the show with uh with the
song and sometimes
an album just grows on you and i um
i
i don't know i've been listening to this
on and off but then it just really stuck
with me in the last week it's kanye's
new album so i don't know if you're
kanye west fan but uh i am so i thought
we would end this episode with okay okay
it's from his new album donda by the way
we have a bunch more surprise questions
this week don't we emma
yes questions such as where do you find
happiness why do we cling to unhappy
relationships and how do we let go of
them how do we determine when it is time
to let go of a dream
how do we deal with the emptiness we
feel when we stop clinging plus a
million more questions for lisa and the
minimalists
if you want to hear all that check out
the minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com the minimalist so
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app you'll also
gain immediate access to hundreds of
hours of private archives recordings of
live events
monthly ask the minimalist anything
sessions and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you subscribe today at patreon.com
theminimalists you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalist.com tour to find a city
near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast theminimalist.com
comment on this episode at youtube.com
the minimalists and if you want our show
notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list at
theminimalist.com you'll receive our
simple sunday newsletter for free
all right well lisa i think we should
end them today with uh with one message
if you leave here today with just one
message let it be this
love people and use things
it's true because i've tried the
opposite for 50 years and it did not
work
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it